We talk a lot on this podcast about relationships, and there's no doubt that relationships can be an important driver of many people's health, happiness, and well-being. But focusing solely on partnerships or romantic relationships misses a crucial fact. More Americans than ever before are single, and many are perfectly happy to stay that way. A 2019 Pew Research Center poll found that 3 and 10 U.S. adults are single. They're not married, living with a partner, or in a committed relationship. relationship. Among those singles, half said they were not interested in dating or looking for a relationship. Meanwhile, looking simply at marriage rates, we find the number of singles is even higher.
我们在这个播客中经常讨论人际关系，毫无疑问，人际关系可以是许多人健康、幸福和福祉的重要驱动力。但如果只关注伴侣关系或恋爱关系，就会忽视一个关键事实：现在的单身美国人比以往任何时候都多，而且许多人非常乐意保持单身。皮尤研究中心 2019 年的一项民意调查发现，十分之三的美国成年人是单身。他们没有结婚，没有与伴侣同居，也没有处于承诺关系中。在这些单身人士中，有一半表示他们对约会或寻找恋爱关系不感兴趣。与此同时，单从结婚率来看，我们会发现单身人数甚至更高。
According to the U.S. Census Bureau, about 50% of American adults are unmarried or close to 127 million people. Those singles are a diverse bunch. Some have never been married. Some are divorced, some widowed. They are older or younger. Some are parents. Others have no children. All of the those factors and many others may affect how people experience singlehood. So how is relationship status related to well-being? What makes some people happy with singlehood while others are not? Is there a societal stigma against singles? And if so, how does that stigma affect people's lives? Why is there so much more research on being in a happy relationship than on being happily single? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that
根据美国人口普查局的数据，大约 50% 的美国成年人未婚，相当于近 1.27 亿人。这些单身人士是一个多元化的群体。有些人从未结过婚。有些人离异，有些人丧偶。他们有老有少。有些人是父母。其他人没有孩子。所有这些因素以及许多其他因素都可能会影响人们对单身生活的体验。那么，恋爱状态与幸福感之间有什么关系？是什么让一些人对单身生活感到快乐，而另一些人则不然？社会上对单身人士是否存在污名化？如果是这样，这种污名化如何影响人们的生活？为什么关于拥有幸福恋爱关系的研究远多于关于享受单身的研究？欢迎收听《心理学对话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，
examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Jeff McDonald, a professor of psychology at the University of Toronto. He has studied aspects of relationships for many years, including attachment theory and intimacy. More recently, he turned his attention to singlehood, and today, the primary aim of his lab is to better understand well-being in singlehood. His and his colleagues' research has started to create a portrait of what makes for a happy single person. So I'm looking forward to talking today about that and much more. Thank you for joining me, Dr. McDonald. That's my pleasure to be here.
旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是多伦多大学心理学教授杰夫·麦克唐纳博士。他多年来一直研究人际关系的各个方面，包括依恋理论和亲密关系。最近，他将注意力转向了单身生活，今天，他的实验室的主要目标是更好地了解单身状态下的福祉。他和同事的研究开始描绘出一幅什么样的单身人士才算快乐的画像。所以我很期待今天能聊聊这个话题以及更多内容。谢谢你加入我们，麦克唐纳博士。很高兴来到这里。
I mentioned that you studied relationships for many years before you started studying singlehood. What made you turn your attention to single people and why do you think it's important for researchers to study singlehood? I mean, I think the primary driver in turning my attention to singlehood is just recognizing, you know, like you said at the top there, there are a lot of single people out there, and that number is increasing, not just in the United States, not just in Canada. This seems to be a worldwide trend. So it's something that's important to pay attention to, but we know really very little about
我提到你在开始研究单身之前研究了多年的人际关系。是什么让你把注意力转向单身人士？你为什么认为研究单身对研究人员来说很重要？我的意思是，我将注意力转向单身的主要驱动力只是认识到，正如你在开场时所说的那样，有很多人是单身，而且这个数字还在不断增加，不仅在美国，不仅在加拿大。这似乎是一个全球性的趋势。所以这是值得关注的事情，但我们对
who single people are and what makes single people happy. And even if you just want to take this from the perspective of a relationship researcher, everybody is single before they get in their first relationship. Most of the time when you end a relationship, you end up single. So, you know, it's important to not think about this as two different groups of people, largely speaking. These are different phases of most people's lives. And so even if your goal is just to understand relationships, you need to understand singlehood. But I think understanding single people is important in its own right.
单身人士是谁以及是什么让他们快乐知之甚少。即使你只是想从关系研究人员的角度来看，每个人在建立第一段关系之前都是单身的。大多数时候，当你结束一段关系时，你最终也会恢复单身。所以，从广义上讲，不要把这看作是两类不同的人，这一点很重要。这些是大多数人生活中的不同阶段。因此，即使你的目标只是了解人际关系，你也需要了解单身生活。但我认为理解单身人士本身就很重要。
So a lot of research over the years has found evidence that on average, married people are happier, healthier, and generally have better life outcomes compared with single people. But some researchers who study singlehood have pushed back again. that idea. What do you think? Are partnered people generally better off than those who are single? Is that even the right question to ask? I think it's one of the right questions to ask, but it's not the only one. And, you know, I certainly think I should say off the top that this is such a young field of research. So we have some initial things to say about it. But I think all of this is up for debate and discussion. You know, from my reading of the literature, I think it would be fair to say that the average person who is in a romantic relationship is higher in well-being. they're happier, they're higher in life satisfaction than the average person who is single. But there's so much variability within each group. Not every single person is miserable and certainly not everybody in a relationship is ecstatic with their life.
因此，多年来的大量研究发现，平均而言，与单身人士相比，已婚人士更幸福、更健康，而且通常会有更好的生活结果。但一些研究单身的研究人员反驳了这种观点。你怎么看？有伴侣的人通常比单身的人过得更好吗？这甚至是一个正确的问题吗？我认为这是正确的问题之一，但不是唯一的问题。而且，我当然应该首先说明，这是一个非常年轻的研究领域。所以我们对此有一些初步的看法。但我认为这一切都悬而未决，有待讨论和辩论。你知道，根据我对文献的阅读，公平地说，平均而言处于恋爱关系中的人在福祉方面更高，他们更快乐，生活满意度比平均单身的人更高。但每个群体内部都有很大的变异性。并不是每个单身的人都很痛苦，当然也不是恋爱中的每个人都对自己的生活欣喜若狂。
So that's really been the focus of what we've been doing at our lab. And I think a lot of singlehood researchers have been doing is looking at who are the happier versus less happy single people to get a sense of, you know, which types of single people are doing really well for themselves. which types of single people might not be doing so well. One of the central questions in your lab is what makes people happy or content with being single. Are there common traits that happy singles share personality traits or life, circumstances, or other things? There's a few things that we seem to be starting to put our finger on now. So one, for example, is that people who have never been married or people who have never been in a romantic relationship tend to be happier singles than people who have been. We don't really have any direct evidence as to why that's the case, but my guess would be people know what's good for them.
所以这确实是我们实验室一直在做的事情的重点，我想很多单身研究人员一直在做的事情就是寻找更快乐与不太快乐的单身人士，以了解哪些类型的单身人士过得很好，哪些类型的单身人士可能过得不是很好。你实验室的核心问题之一是什么让人对单身感到快乐或满足。快乐的单星是否具有共同的特征、人格特质或生活环境或其他东西？现在我们似乎开始掌握一些事情了。例如，一个从来没有结过婚的人或从来没有谈过恋爱的人往往比曾经结过婚的人更快乐。我们真的没有任何直接证据来解释为什么会这样，但我的猜测是人们知道什么对他们有好处。
And there's a reason why some people don't choose to be in romantic relationships because they know that's not what's going to make them happy. And, you know, the flip side of that is that one of the groups that does less well with singlehood is people who've been through a divorce. There is some evidence that suggests that divorce can have a bit of a damaging effect on at least some people, which we think is particularly interesting because the bias tends to be that romantic relationships are good for people. But if you think about the way that people come out of divorces maybe less well off than when they started, relationships can actually be damaging, right? But there's a reason that as a society we haven't thought about relationships is damaging. The assumption is that they're good. So, you know, relationship history, I think, is an important one. Generally speaking, the tack that I tend to take on this is that the people who are doing well in singlehood are sort of the people who are good at life in general.
这就是为什么有些人不选择谈恋爱，因为他们知道那不会让他们快乐。反过来说，单身生活过得不太好的人群之一就是经历过离婚的人。有一些证据表明，离婚会对至少某些人产生一点破坏性影响，我们认为这特别有趣，因为人们往往有一种偏见，即恋爱关系对人有好处。但如果你仔细想想，人们离婚后的生活可能不如开始时那么好，人际关系实际上可能是具有破坏性的，对吧？但这就是为什么作为一个社会，我们没有将人际关系视为具有破坏性的原因。大家的假设是它们是好的。所以，我认为恋爱史是一个重要的因素。总的来说，我对此采取的立场是，单身生活过得好的人通常是那些擅长生活的人。
That, you know, people, for example, who are higher in attachment security. So these would be the kinds of people who are comfortable making close relationships with people and who are not really worried so much about getting rejected by other people. I mean, they do well in romantic relationships, but our evidence suggests that these are people who do well in singlehood as well. Maybe one of the reasons for that is that people who are happier in singlehood are also people who have good relationships with their friends and good relationships with their families. And that skill set that comes with attachment and security, the ability to be comfortably close to people to take emotional risks that allow you to get close to people. That's not just limited to romantic relationships. Those people are going to bring those kinds of skills to their friendships and their family relationships. And I do think, you know, there's a bit of old-fashioned wisdom here that I think that some people have the idea.
例如，那些依恋安全感更高的人。这些人往往是那些习惯与他人建立亲密关系、并不太担心被别人拒绝的人。我的意思是，他们在恋爱关系中表现得很好，但我们的证据表明，这些人在单身生活中也表现得很好。这其中的原因之一可能是，单身时更快乐的人也是那些与朋友和家人关系良好的人。与依恋和安全感相关的技能组合，即能够舒适地亲近他人、承担能够让你亲近他人的情感风险的能力。这不仅限于恋爱关系。这些人会将这种技能带入他们的友谊和家庭关系中。而且我确实认为，这里有一些老式的智慧，我认为有些人有一种想法，
that when you get into a romantic relationship, that then you're going to become a happy person. But when you understand the kinds of people who are happy single are also the kinds of people who are happy in relationships, it suggests that maybe the best idea is to get right with yourself first and go towards a romantic relationship when you've done whatever that work is. Now, when you're studying people who are single, does that mean that they can't have relationships, that they can't have intimacy with other people? Yeah, no, not at all. certainly in terms of their friendship and their family relationships, there's lots of opportunity for intimacy there. One of the projects that we have ongoing in the lab right now is also looking at the romantic
当你进入一段恋爱关系时，你就会成为一个快乐的人。但是，当你了解到单身时快乐的人也是关系中快乐的人时，这表明也许最好的主意是先让自己恢复正常，当做完所有这些工作后，再走向一段恋爱关系。现在，当你研究单身人士时，这是否意味着他们不能有关系，他们不能与其他人有亲密关系？是的，不，一点也不。当然，就他们的友谊和家庭关系而言，有很多机会获得亲密感。我们实验室目前正在进行的另一个项目也是在研究单身人士拥有的浪漫
and sexual kinds of connections that single people have. So certainly, you know, over the last, like however many decades, social norms have changed around opportunities for casual sexual opportunities or relationships that sort of straddle the line between dating and not dating, like friends with benefits. Friends with benefits. That's what I was thinking to. Yeah, exactly. So, you know, we know that there are a number of single people who tell us that they're sexually active.
和性联系。所以当然，在过去的几十几年里，围绕休闲性行为机会或介于约会和不约会之间的关系（比如炮友）的机会的社会规范已经改变了。炮友。我也是这么想的。是的，完全正确。所以，我们知道有许多单身人士告诉我们他们有性生活。
But we haven't really collected the data yet on, well, what kinds of relationships are those? And so we're trying to delve into that a little bit. What we do know is that single people who are higher in sexual satisfaction tend to be happier with singlehood. But the other part of that is that the data suggests to us that singles who are happier with their sex, lives are also more likely to end up in relationships down the road. And so, you know, one of our guesses about that is that, you know, being with people in sexual and romantic relationships, it's not like shopping for a product where if you don't like it, you take it back.
但我们还没有真正收集到关于这些到底是什么样关系的数据。所以我们正在努力深入研究这一点。我们所知道的是，性满意度更高的单身人士往往对单身生活更满意。但另一部分是，数据表明，对性生活更满意的单身人士在未来也更有可能最终建立恋爱关系。所以，我们对此的一个猜测是，与人们建立性和恋爱关系，并不像购买产品那样，如果你不喜欢就可以退货。
You know, the human heart works such that relationships are kind of sticky. And even when you are in casual sexual relationships, for example, next thing, you know, you're leaving a toothbrush. And next thing, you know, you're leaving a set of pajamas. And next thing, you know, it's easier to just move in because you're already spending three nights a week there, right? So we think that even though sexual satisfaction is definitely something that's associated with happiness and singlehood, that might also indicate somebody who's on the road to being in a committed romantic relationship. Let me ask how age affects
你知道，人类的心灵运作方式使得人际关系有点黏人。即使你处于休闲的性关系中，比方说，接下来你知道的，你留下一把牙刷。接下来你知道的，你留下一套睡袍。接下来你知道的，搬进去更容易，因为你已经在那里度过了每周三个晚上，对吧？因此，我们认为，尽管性满意度绝对是与幸福和单身有关的事情，但这可能也表明某人正在走向承诺的恋爱关系。让我问一下年龄如何影响
people's experience of singlehood. Do people become more or less content with being single as they get older? So our evidence suggests that there's kind of an inflection point around midlife, that single people starting at about age 40 start to become more satisfied with being single. It's important to point out that's not unique to singlehood, that it looks like there's some evidence suggesting that well-being in general for people tends to increase after about midlife. So there's another study by Unina Bueller where she looked at are people happy with the romantic
人们对单身的体验。随着年龄的增长，人们对单身的满意度是增加还是减少？我们的证据表明，中年左右有一个拐点，从 40 岁左右开始的单身人士开始对单身感到更满意。需要指出的是，这并不是单身生活所独有的，一些证据表明，人们总体的福祉在 40 岁中年以后往往会增加。因此，尤娜·布勒（Unina Bueller）的另一项研究探讨了人们是否对浪漫关系感到幸福？
relationships? And she found exactly the same pattern. Starting at about age 40, people start to become. happier with the relationship. So, you know, it kind of looks like around midlife, people start to become happier with the path that they've chosen. I do think another factor in that, though, is some people who want to be in a relationship get selected out of the singles pool, that if you're younger and you'd really like to be in a relationship, you're more likely to actually end up dating. And so maybe the part of the reason that older singles are happier being single is that there's
她发现了完全相同的模式。从 40 岁左右开始，人们开始对这种关系感到更快乐。所以，这看起来就像在中年左右，人们开始对他们选择的道路感到更快乐。不过，我认为其中的另一个因素是，一些想要恋爱的人被从单身池中筛选出去了，如果你更年轻并且真的很想恋爱，你更有可能真正去约会。因此，年长单身人士更喜欢单身的部分原因可能是，
going to be less of them in that pool who wish that they were in a relationship. Now, having said that, in another study that we conducted, what the data look like is that for older people who don't let go of wanting a relationship, like that variable, do you want to be in a romantic relationship or not, also seems to be something that's important in understanding whether people are happy with being single or not, that particularly older women who have let go of the desire or who never had a desire for romantic relationship in the first place are our highest group in terms of life satisfaction. But it's the people who, as they get older, continue to wish that they were in a romantic relationship.
在这个群体中，希望自己处于恋爱关系中的人会更少。话虽如此，在我们进行的另一项研究中，数据表明，对于那些不放弃渴望恋爱关系的老年人来说，比如“你想谈恋爱吗”这个变量，对于理解人们是否对单身感到快乐似乎也很重要，特别是那些已经放弃了对恋爱关系的渴望或者从来没有渴望过恋爱关系的年长女性，在生活满意度方面是我们最高的一群人。但随着年龄的增长，那些继续希望自己处于恋爱关系中的人，
That seems to be associated with lower life satisfaction. So there's something about making peace with your circumstances, letting go of things that you can't have that might also be part of this process of becoming a happy single person in an older age. I believe that most of your research is with people in the U.S., right? We've conducted studies with people in the U.S., with Europeans. We've done a little bit of data collection in Korea, but we haven't really expanded out culturally beyond that. Are there cultural differences, then?
这似乎与较低的生活满意度有关。因此，与你的环境人和解，放手你无法拥有的东西，这也可能是迈向老年快乐单身人士过程的一部分。我相信你的大部分研究对象都是美国人，对吧？我们对美国人、欧洲人进行了研究。我们在韩国收集了一点数据，但我们并没有真正在文化上进一步扩展。那么，是否存在文化差异呢？
In the research that you've done, have you found in other countries that there is a difference in singlehood, how it's experienced and how it's perceived? You know, I would say that so far, we haven't collected enough data to be able to answer that question well. I think it is such an important question. I mean, I would say so far with the research that we've been conducting in Korea, we've been surprised at the similarities across the two cultures. So, for example, when you ask single people, you know, what are your most important life priorities in both Korea and in the West where we've collected data, they say, my most important priorities are my family and my health. And they say that my least important priorities, at least of the ones that we ask them, are sex and dating. And that was something that was consistent across those two countries. But one of the things that we've speculated about, and there has been a little bit of research in other labs about, is the role that family plays in single people's lives across different cultures.
在你做过的研究中，你发现在其他国家，单身的体验和看法是否存在差异？你知道，我想说的是，到目前为止，我们还没有收集到足够的数据来很好地回答这个问题。我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。我的意思是，我想说的是，到目前为止，通过我们在韩国进行的研究所做的事情，我们对两种文化之间的相似之处感到惊讶。例如，当你问单身人士，你在韩国和我们收集数据的西方最重要的生活优先事项是什么时，他们说，我最重要的优先事项是我的家庭和健康。他们说，我最不重要的优先事项（至少在我们问过的事项中）是性和约会。这在两个国家是一致的。但我们推测的一件事（其他实验室也进行了一些研究）是家庭在不同文化的单身人士生活中所起的作用。
You know, the U.S. in particular is unique. It is, you know, by some measures, literally the most individualistic country in the world, which means that it's a system where your family doesn't have a lot of say in what you're dating and your marriage life is. that's really unusual. In most countries around the world, family has a pretty big say about, you know, are you dating? Who are you dating? That kind of thing. And so it would make sense that that would lead to some kind of intense dynamics for single people in these more collectivistic kinds of countries where we would expect because there's these cultural norms around you're a representative of our family. You're supposed to be getting married. You're making us look bad by not getting married. That there could be some particular pressure on them to, not be single, even if that in their heart is what they want to be. So I think that's going to be a really important direction for future research. We don't have a lot to say about that yet. Are you finding differences between the sexes? Are single men happier than single women or vice versa? We've been surprised in that regard. We have looked at gender differences in a number of our studies and haven't found a lot of differences between men and women. I know that there's
你知道，美国尤其独特。从某些指标来看，它实际上是世界上最具个人主义的国家，这意味着这是一个你的家庭对你的约会和婚姻生活没有太多发言权的系统。这真的很不寻常。世界上大多数国家，家庭对你是否约会、你在和谁约会等事情都有很大的发言权。因此，这在这些更具集体主义色彩的国家中，会导致单身人士出现某种激烈的动态变化，这是合乎情理的，因为我们预计由于这些文化规范围绕着你代表着我们的家庭。你应该结婚。你没有结婚让我们看起来很糟糕。他们可能会面临一些特殊的压力，即不要单身，即使这在他们心底是他们想要成为的人。所以我认为这将是未来研究的一个非常重要的方向。我们对此还没有太多要说的。你发现两性之间存在差异吗？单身男性比单身女性更快乐，反之亦然？在这方面我们很惊讶。我们在许多研究中研究了性别差异，并没有发现男性和女性之间有很多差异。我知道
some sort of cultural tropes that men in particular as they get older, are going to really struggle with singlehood. Generally speaking, the data so far are more equivocal on that. You know, it does seem to be true that men, when they're single, struggle more than women do with social support, so that men will tend to have, like, less supportive friendships, for example, and so that can be a bit of a struggle for them. But generally speaking, the data that we've been looking at, the numbers in terms of, like, how on average, Are you happy with singlehood, for example? There doesn't tend to be a lot of difference. What we suspect is that underneath those numbers, the content of people's experiences might
有一些文化俗语，尤其是男性随着年龄的增长，会真正难以适应单身生活。总的来说，到目前为止的数据对此更加模棱两可。你知道，单身时，男性在社会支持方面确实比女性挣扎得更多，例如，男性的支持性友谊往往较少，因此这对他们来说可能有点挣扎。但总的来说，我们一直在研究的数据，就平均而言，你对单身生活有多满意等数字而言。往往没有太多的区别。我们怀疑的是，在这些数字背后，人们的经历内容可能会
be different. So, you know, for example, if you are a single woman, there's going to be different stereotypes about you than if you're a single man, right? Like women, for example, are seen as cold if they're single, and that might not necessarily be the case for men. And there are some negative words that define women who are single like spinster. There's nothing quite equivalent for a man. No, there's not.
有所不同。所以，例如，如果你是一个单身女性，人们对你的刻板印象会与你是一个单身男性不同，对吧？例如，如果女性单身，她们会被视为冷漠，而男性则不一定如此。而且有些负面词汇用来定义单身女性，比如“老处女”（spinster）。对于男性来说，没有什么完全等同的词。不，并没有。
Not yet anyways. A few moments ago, you talked about attachment in singlehood. I'm wondering if you could talk a little bit more about attachment theory and how that relates to singlehood and the work that you do. Sure, yeah. So attachment theory is, you know, basically a theory to explain why is it that some people are more comfortable getting close to others than other people are? You know, the original development of theory had this very psychodynamic kind of event to it where the idea was you get treated a particular way in childhood and that teaches you how to interact with other people.
无论如何，还没有。刚才，你谈到了单身时的依恋。我想知道你是否可以多谈谈依恋理论以及它与单身和你所做的工作的关系。当然，是的。所以依恋理论，基本上是一个用来解释为什么有些人比其他人更乐于亲近他人的理论？你知道，该理论的最初发展具有非常心理动力学式的事件，其想法是你在童年中受到某种特定的对待，这教会了你如何与其他人互动。
More recently, there's been some longitudinal research that has looked at, you know, how much of this is really rooted in childhood. And there's some questions about that. So, you know, I think that that part of attachment being about childhood is a little bit in flux these days. But what is absolutely clear from an attachment theory perspective is that you can measure stable personality differences in how people relate to other people. So the two dimensions on which we typically think of differences in people about how they relate to others are these two variables that we call anxious attachment and avoidant attachment. So anxiously attached people, I mean, these are the kinds of people who you would sort of colloquially think about is the needy and clingy type. So the person who needs a lot of attention, they want validation because they don't feel so great about themselves. But they also feel really hesitant in approaching other people because they're really scared of getting rejected.
最近，有一些纵向研究探讨了，这其中有多少真正植根于童年。对此有一些疑问。所以，你知道，我认为依恋关于童年的那部分现在有点处于流动状态。但从依恋理论的角度来看，绝对清楚的是，你可以衡量人们如何与他人建立关系的稳定人格差异。因此，我们通常用来思考人们如何与他人建立关系的差异的两个维度，是我们称之为焦虑依恋和回避依恋这两个变量。对于焦虑依恋的人，我的意思是，这些人就是你在日常生活中认为的需要照顾和粘人的类型。所以这个人需要很多关注，他们想要验证，因为他们对自己感觉不太好。但他们在接近其他人时也感到非常犹豫，因为他们真的很害怕被拒绝。
So they can have this kind of strong approach of wind's dynamic going on in their relationships. With avoidantly attached people, avoidantly attached people, they're the kinds of people who you would think of as the independent type. They're the person who's likely to tell you that they don't really need relationships. I always like to say that if you're the person when there's eight bags of groceries to carry from the car into the house that you want to take them all by yourself, you might be avoidantly attached. They're the kinds of people who don't really like to be reliant on other people, don't like to get a lot of help from other people. So we have a little bit of research looking at, you know, do these individual differences in how people relate to other people? Are they related to how happy people are in singlehood? And so it turns out the people who are more anxiously attached.
因此，他们在人际关系中会有这种强烈的“接近-回避”动态。对于回避型依恋的人，回避型依恋的人，他们是你会认为是独立类型的人。他们很可能会告诉你他们并不真正需要关系。我总是喜欢说，如果你是那种当车里有八袋杂货要搬进屋里时想自己一个人全搬完的人，你可能是回避型依恋。他们是那些真正不喜欢依赖他人、不喜欢从他人那里获得太多帮助的人。因此，我们做了一些研究，探讨人们如何与他人建立关系的这些个体差异吗？它们与人们在单身时的快乐程度有关吗？事实证明，依恋焦虑程度更高的人。
And again, these are the needy and clingy type. They have a bit of a sense that they can't quite get through life without other people. They're not very happy with being single. So single anxiously attached people are relatively low in their overall life satisfaction. They're relatively low in how satisfied they are with singlehood. So they feel like they really need a relationship. I mean, the unfortunate thing for anxiously attached people is that they're also, when they do get into relationships, tend to have relatively low relationship satisfaction.
同样，这些是需要和粘人的类型。他们有一种没有其他人就无法度过生活的感觉。他们对单身很不快乐。因此，焦虑依恋的单身人士的总体生活满意度相对较低。他们对单身生活的满意度相对较低。所以他们觉得他们真的很需要恋爱关系。我的意思是，对于焦虑依恋的人来说，不幸的是，当他们真正进入恋爱关系时，他们的关系满意度往往相对较低。
So it's kind of like they have this story. If I just get into a relationship, I'll be okay. And it turns out that that doesn't quite work. And so that definitely goes back to what I was saying before, that there's some people who probably need to work on themselves first before they're ready for a relationship. And that might particularly be the anxiously attached people. avoidantly attached people are a bit of a curious case in that avoidantly attached people are not particularly unhappy about being single. So they're no less satisfied with singlehood than your more secure type of person, but they do seem to be lower in overall life satisfaction. So they're interesting to me because they say that they're not unhappy about being single.
所以这有点像他们有一个故事。如果我能谈恋爱，我就没事了。事实证明，这并不完全奏效。这绝对回到了我之前所说的话，有些人可能需要先自我完善，然后才能准备好恋爱。而焦虑依恋的人可能尤其如此。回避型依恋的人是一个奇怪的例子，因为回避型依恋的人并不是特别对单身感到不高兴。所以他们对单身的满意度并不比你那种更安全类型的人低，但他们的整体生活满意度似乎更低。所以他们对我很有趣，因为他们说他们并不对单身感到不高兴。
They don't report particularly wanting a romantic partner, but something is going on that's leading to them to feel less happy in life overall. One of the things that we've speculated there, and this came from my graduate student, an amazing collaborator, Ubin Park. Her idea, which I think is a really good one, is that with avoidantly attached people, again, they like distance, right? They don't like to get too close to people, but that doesn't just apply to their romantic relationships. And as we talked about before, to be a happy single, it's going to help a lot to have close relationships with your family and with your friends. And avoidantly attached people struggle in those kinds of domains, too, because they keep their emotional distance there. And there is some research
他们并没有特别报告想要一个浪漫的伴侣，但有些事情正在发生，导致他们对整体生活的幸福感降低。我们对此推测的一件事是，这来自我的研究生、出色的合作者乌宾·帕克（Ubin Park）。她的想法，我认为非常好，就是对于回避型依恋的人来说，他们再次喜欢距离，对吧？他们不喜欢离人太近，但这不仅适用于他们的恋爱关系。正如我们之前所讨论的，要成为一个快乐的单身人士，与家人和朋友建立亲密关系将大有帮助。回避型依恋的人在这些领域也苦苦挣扎，因为他们在那里保持着情感距离。还有一些研究
that suggests that this is avoidantly attached people, even though it feels better or easier for them in the short term to avoid those kinds of relationships, if you actually do, like in an experimental study, kind of push them a little bit to get into an emotional, intimate situation. I mean, I always say that for avoidantly attached people, intimacy is like exercise. It doesn't feel good in the moment, but it builds capacity over the long term, right? And so they do seem to get something good out of those close interactions. They just don't seem to be motivated to push themselves into them. So that's one reason we think that avoidantly attach people are kind of attracted to being single because you can avoid all the problems and the conflicts that
这表明，这是回避型依恋的人，尽管在短期内避免这种关系让他们感觉更好或更容易，如果你真的这样做，比如在实验研究中，有点推动他们进入一个情感亲密的境地。我的意思是，我总是说对于回避型依恋的人来说，亲密关系就像锻炼。当时感觉不好，但从长远来看它建立能力，对吧？因此，他们似乎确实从这些密切的互动中得到了一些好处。他们似乎只是没有动力去强迫自己进入这些状态。这就是我们认为回避依恋的人有点被单身吸引的原因之一，因为你可以避免所有的麻烦和冲突
come with relationships. But the flip side of that is that you don't get the benefits of relationships. You've also looked at something called progression bias, which, as I understand it, is the tendency among people to stay in relationships, even when they're not that great. From an evolutionary perspective, aren't we almost hardwired to try to stay coupled even when it's not optimal? It's a really good question. Yeah. So this is some work that I've done with my former PhD student, and she's now a professor at Western University, Samantha Joel. And the idea with progression bias is it's kind of like I was talking about before when you get into a casual sexual sexual relationship and then it's all of a sudden you find yourself more and more committed.
伴随着关系而来。但另一面是你没有得到关系的好处。你还研究了一种叫做“进展偏见”的东西，据我了解，这是人们倾向于保持关系的倾向，即使它们并不是那么好。从进化的角度来看，即使在不是最优的情况下，我们难道不是几乎被硬编码为试图保持伴侣关系吗？这是一个非常好的问题。是的。所以这是我与前博士生萨曼莎·乔尔（Samantha Joel）共同完成的一些工作，她现在是韦士敦大学的教授。进展偏见的想法有点像我之前谈到的，当你进入一段休闲的性关系时，突然之间你发现自己越来越投入。
What we think is that we think that there's a couple of reasons why this might be. And one of them is definitely the evolutionary case that you're bringing up there. That, you know, our thinking on this is our ancestors long, long ago, right? If you think about hunter-gatherer groups living in relatively small numbers of people, that if he kind of took the online dating strategy of like swiping left on everyone until you came to your like absolute perfect match. I mean, there's only 30 people that you could possibly date. You might end up rejecting everybody and you're not going to pass your jeans down because
我们认为这可能是由于几个原因。其中之一绝对是你提到的进化案例。你知道，我们对此的想法是我们很久很久以前的祖先，对吧？如果你想想生活在相对较少人数中的狩猎采集群体，如果他采用像在所有人向左滑动这样的在线约会策略，直到你找到你绝对完美的匹配。我的意思是，只有 30 个人是你可能约会的对象。你可能会最终拒绝所有人，而你不会把你的基因传下去，因为
you're not mating with anybody, right? If the human heart is kind of built to just sort of fall for somebody and make that work relatively easily, then that might have been sort of a successful strategy for people living in those relatively small groups. And so we think that it is true that people in relationships are kind of biased toward keeping the relationship going, sometimes even if it's not the happiest relationship, because that might have been evolutionarily useful. But having said that, we don't think that the evolution part of it is the only part of the story. There's all kinds of social and structural systems, as we've talked
你没有和任何人交配，对吧？如果人类的心灵被建造为只是爱上某人并相对容易地使之工作，那么这对于生活在那些相对较小的群体中的人们来说可能是一个成功的策略。因此，我们认为，恋爱中的人确实倾向于保持关系继续下去，有时即使这不是最幸福的关系，因为这可能在进化上有用。话虽如此，我们并不认为进化的部分是故事的全部。正如我们今天所讨论的，还有各种各样的社会和结构系统，
about today, that are also biased towards relationships that give people the sense that you're supposed to be in a relationship. And one of the things that we argue in my lab is make it hard for people to notice sometimes if they're happier being single. You're not looking at. You're not looking for that when you're raised in a society where you expect relationships to be what makes you happy. So we think that there's two really powerful forces happening. We do think that the human heart kind of, you know, gets itself stuck in relationships sometimes. But we also think there's a lot of social pressure to get into and to stay in relationships.
它们也偏向于关系，给人一种你本该处于一段关系中的感觉。我们在我的实验室里争论的一件事情是，有时很难让人们注意到他们是否作为单身人士更快乐。当你生活在一个期望关系能让你快乐的社会中时，你不会寻找这个。所以我们认为有两股非常强大的力量在发生。我们确实认为人类的心灵有时会陷入关系中。但我们也认为，有很多社会压力让人进入并保持在关系中。
Which raises the question of societal stigma then against singlehood, which it seems you're saying is pervasive. Is that really a bad thing? It's certainly a bad thing for single people. If you're trying to, well, if you're trying to build a society where you want people to stay stuck in relationships, it's great. But if you're a single person who wants to be single and is living their best and happiest life as a single person, it can be a really negative force in people's lives. And I think that one of the problems with discrimination against single people is that to a certain extent, it's still kind of an acceptance. I think people have internalized the idea that there's something wrong with single people.
这就引发了人们对单身生活的社会污名化问题，这似乎在说这种污名化是无处不在的。这真的是一件坏事吗？对于单身人士来说，这绝对是一件坏事。如果你试图，好吧，如果你试图建立一个希望人们留在关系中的社会，那是很棒的。但如果你是一个单身人士，想要单身并作为单身人士过着最好、最快乐的生活，这可能是人们生活中的一股非常负面的力量。我认为对单身人士歧视的问题之一是，在某种程度上，这仍然是一种认可。我认为人们已经内化了这样一种观点，即单身人士出了问题。
And so it doesn't even feel like unfair discrimination when, for example, and this is something that data has shown, people are more likely to rent an apartment to somebody who's in a relationship than somebody who is single, right? That if you get into a big health crisis and your social support is your best friend, they may not be able to get into the emergency room with you. But if it's your wife or your husband, there's no problem there whatsoever. So it can create some really important barriers in people's lives. Bella DiPaula is someone who's talked about this extensively, and I think she makes a really good argument here, that these are some forces that not only affect single people's lives negatively, but I think a lot of people are only just realizing that these are unfair stereotypes.
所以，当例如（并且有数据表明这一点）人们更有可能将公寓租给处于恋爱关系中的人而不是单身人士时，这甚至不像是不公平的歧视，对吧？如果你遇到了严重的健康危机，你的社会支持是你最好的朋友，他们可能无法和你一起进入急诊室。但如果是你的妻子或丈夫，那就完全没有问题了。因此，它可能会在人们的生活中造成一些非常重要的障碍。贝拉·迪保拉（Bella DiPaula）是一个广泛讨论过这一点的人，我认为她在这里提出了一个很好的论点，即这些力量不仅对单身人士的生活产生负面影响，而且我认为很多人才刚刚意识到这些是不公平的刻板印象。
Do you think that the pandemic affected how some people think about being single? And I'm asking because at the beginning of the pandemic, many people were strictly social distancing. And there were lots of news stories about how social distancing was particularly difficult for single people, especially those who were living alone. Was that just a temporary blip that we're done with now that social distancing is over? Or do you think this is going to have some kind of lasting effect on how people treat and value relationships? I think that's a very interesting question. There's not a lot of data on this point. So I'm just going to go ahead and speculate now.
你认为大流行影响了某些人对单身的看法吗？我这样问是因为在大流行开始时，许多人都在严格保持社交距离。有很多关于社交距离对单身人士尤其困难的新闻报道，尤其是那些独居的人。这只是一个暂时的插曲，现在社交距离已经结束，我们就结束了吗？还是你认为这会对人们对待和重视关系的方式产生某种持久的影响？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题。关于这一点没有多少数据。所以我现在要继续推测了。
But, you know, I think that the reason why more and more people have been living single is that we've been structuring society in a way that makes it easier and easier for people to do so. That, you know, the economic system is set up in a way that we don't need to be as dependent on close others as we did 100 or 200 years ago. So the people who really like their independence can do that in a practical kind of way now. But I think that the pandemic was kind of a reminder. of that, you know, it's not that more people are becoming single because there's something inevitably correct about the societal move. I think it's people are adjusting themselves to the society that they live in. And during the pandemic, when people were more housebound, you didn't
但是，你知道，我认为越来越多的人过着单身生活的原因是，我们一直在以一种让人们更容易做到这一点的方式构建社会。你知道，经济系统的建立方式使我们不需要像 100 或 200 年前那样依赖亲密的其他人。因此，那些真正喜欢独立的人现在可以以一种实际的方式做到这一点。但我认为大流行是一种提醒。关于这一点，你知道，并不是越来越多的人单身，因为社会的这种变迁有什么不可避免的正确性。我认为人们正在适应他们所生活的社会。在大流行期间，当人们更多地呆在家里时，你没有
have access to the kinds of social networks that make it easier to live as a happy single person. So, you know, for example, I think a lot of the discourse around, you know, who was really struggling during the pandemic. A lot of this discourse is, you know, people, with kids, for example, you know, how do you balance the workplace and kids and all this kind of stuff? All of which is totally valid. You know, having kids during the pandemic was a real challenge. But when you look at the data as to who was the most happy versus who was the least happy during the pandemic, it was people living with partners and children who were the most happy, right? You might be stressed, but you're stimulated. You're not bored. The people were having the
获得使单身生活更容易的社交网络的机会。所以，你知道，例如，我认为围绕大流行期间谁真正挣扎的讨论很多。很多这种讨论是，有孩子的家庭，例如，你如何平衡工作场所和孩子以及所有这些事情？所有这些都是完全正确的。在大流行期间生孩子是一个真正的挑战。但当你查看关于大流行期间谁最快乐与谁最不快乐的数据时，是与伴侣和孩子住在一起的人最快乐，对吧？你可能会感到压力，但你得到了刺激。你并不觉得无聊。
hardest time were the people who were living by themselves, that there is something about just not having any stimulation and social connection in your environment that can be really challenging. So I think that was something that got people to think twice anyways about, you know, how sustainable is a single life. And then I think it's interesting to think about what are the future social structural changes that might drive people into different kinds of living circumstances. So, for example, you know, here in Toronto, rent and house prices are out of control, that people who might have been able to afford to live on their own in the past are going to be forced into more group living situations.
最艰难的时刻是那些独自生活的人，仅仅是环境中没有任何刺激和社交连接，这确实具有挑战性。所以我认为这让人们无论如何都三思而后行，关于单身生活的可持续性如何。然后我认为思考未来可能推动人们进入不同生活环境的社会结构变化很有趣。例如，你知道，在多伦多，房租和房价失控了，过去可能买得起自己住的人将被迫进入更多的小组生活情况。
But maybe when you've got a roommate, that accounts for some of the need that you might have had a romantic partner for, right? So maybe there's another force that leads people to be less motivated to be in romantic relationships. So I think it's completely unpredictable. Are people going to be living single more or be living single less? I think it really depends on, you know, what happens to society and what are the opportunities and challenges for single people. So I think that's the important thing to remember
但也许当你有一个室友时，这就满足了你可能需要的浪漫伴侣的需求的一部分，对吧？所以也许还有另一股力量导致人们谈恋爱的动力降低。所以我认为这是完全不可预测的。人们会更多地过单身生活还是更少地过单身生活？我认为这完全取决于社会发生了什么，以及对单身人士的机会和挑战是什么。所以我认为这是需要记住的重要事情
is that it's not just some amazing moral choice to live single or to not live single. All of us are trying to just get by in the society that we live in. And that society is constantly changing. This is a relatively young field with a lot of wide open questions. And I'm wondering what are some of the most important research questions that you still want to explore? I'd say that the thing that is in the front of our mind in my lab right now is that, and you know, maybe this is a little bit because we came to singlehood research as relationship researchers. And so I think that as we've been doing singlehood research, a lot of our focus has been on
选择单身或不单身并不仅仅是一个了不起的道德选择。我们所有人都在努力在我们所生活的社会中勉强维生。而这个社会在不断变化。这是一个相对年轻的领域，有许多悬而未决的问题。我想知道，你仍然想要探索的最重要的研究问题有哪些？我想说，现在我们实验室最关心的核心问题是，你知道，也许这在一定程度上是因为我们作为亲密关系研究人员进入了单身研究领域。因此，我认为在我们进行单身研究的过程中，我们的许多重点一直放在
are they dating? Do they want to date? Are they having sex? Do they want to have sex? And so our focus has been this narrow kind of dating and sexual domain. But we've started to do some studies that I've alluded to a little bit where we're asking about single people's broader lives and refining out things like sex and dating is relatively low on their priority list, that things like their health, things like their workplace, for example,
他们在约会吗？他们想约会吗？他们在过性生活吗？他们想过性生活吗？因此，我们的焦点一直局限在约会和性这一个狭窄的领域。但我们已经开始做一些我之前稍微提到过的研究，我们在调查单身人士更广泛的生活，并发现诸如性与约会之类的事情在他们的优先事项中排名相对较低，而诸如他们的健康、他们的工作场所等事情，例如，
are really important factors. So I think because, in a sense, single people are defined as people who have the absence of a romantic relationship that's led us to think that everything about their life surrounds a romantic relationship. I think for a lot of happy singles, they don't even think about romantic relationships. There's a lot of other parts of their life that are more important, but I don't think we've done a good enough job of studying single people's lives holistically in that sense. Well, it sounds like a really interesting area to be researching. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. McDonald. I really appreciated your taking the time. It's been my pleasure. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.
才是真正重要的因素。所以我想，从某种意义上说，单身人士被定义为缺乏浪漫关系的人，这导致我们认为他们生活的一切都围绕着浪漫关系。我认为对于许多快乐的单身人士来说，他们甚至根本不会想到浪漫关系。他们生活中有很多其他部分更重要，但我认为我们还没有在那个意义上把单身人士的生活作为一个整体进行足够好的研究。嗯，听起来这是一个非常有趣的研究领域。谢谢你今天能来，麦克唐纳博士。非常感谢你抽出时间。这是我的荣幸。谢谢你。你可以在我们的网站 www. 上找到《心理学对话》往期节目
speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 以及你获取播客的任何平台上收听。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发邮件至 speakingofpsychology at APA.org 联系我们。《心理学对话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·康丁（Chris Kondyin）。感谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。